prochaine bonjour et merci d'être au
vert en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors l'iran pointé du doigt encore une
fois du déjà vu à maintes reprise c'est
un bras de fer qui s'inscrit dans le
cadre des tensions autour de la question
du nucléaire iranien selon vous bonjour
merci pour votre habitation
oui en fait c'est dans le cadre du
programme nucléaire et de manière plus
générale dans le cadre de cette région
où deux puissances s'affrontent de
manière indirecte mais ne veulent pas
s'affronter directement vous faire un
parallèle c'est quand les états unis et
l'urss affrontait donc ces deux pays
veulent affirmer leur puissance chacun
mènent des actes de sabotage envers
notre pays
l'israël attaque les positions
iraniennes en syrie au liban et l'iran à
cette clique de la manière qu'ils
peuvent la question la plus importante
c'est de savoir à quel moment une ligne
rouge sera dépassée et qu'une guerre
directe sera lancée telle est la
question la plus importante
alors vous l'avez dit un des attaques
plus tôt en syrie voilà qui vise
justement les intérêts iraniens
aujourd'hui on
on assiste voilà un conflit plus tôt en
mer on voit également les occidentaux
bien évidemment qui sont alliés d'israël
et les états unis en particulier
voilà qui pointe du doigt également
l'iran quelles preuves pourraient
justement détenir israël qui affirme que
cette attaque finalement et est bien
bien été mené par la république
islamique pour vous dire vrai je ne peux
pas je ne connais pas les preuves qu'ils
peuvent avoir
mais ce qui est sûr et certain c'est que
vous savez quand l'iran mènent des actes
de sabotage et nie tout le temps en fait
c'est celle s ce qui passe son temps
l'x flexible et ils assassinent des
paysans des scientifiques iraniens tout
le monde du x et israël et l'israël ne
nie pas et ne dis pas que les iraniens
feront la même chose même des attaques
ciblées ils font des sabotages
l'israël pointe du doigt l'iran les
occidentaux qui sont tous les alliés
d'israël et notamment les américains qui
disent aujourd'hui qu'ils veulent eux
répliquaient au nom de quoi on sait pas
et disent que c'est l'iran et l'iran tu
fais comme israël comme tout autre pays
en niant les faits en disant que ce
n'est pas nous mais en plus on peut on
peut estimer que dans chacun des cas les
deux pays disent la vérité et les deux
pays ne veut jamais accepté que c'est de
leur part et quand le premier ministre
israélien dit que l'iran doivent faire
face à ses responsabilités et accepté de
porter de la responsabilité de cette
attaque
eux mêmes quand ils attaquent des
bateaux iraniens ou quand ils font des
achats des assassinats ciblés ne dit
jamais eu et neu neu neu n'accepte pas
c'est de porter cette responsabilité
alors les états unis qui menacent
également d'apporter une réponse
appropriée à ce qui vient de se dérouler
donc la semaine dernière en mer dauman
tel aviv qui demande voilà des sanctions
de la part de la communauté
internationale
quelle sanction on sait déjà que l'iran
est sous le coup de plusieurs sanctions
justement concernant le pétrole
exactement en fait de l'israël demande à
ce que la communauté internationale
impose de nouvelles sanctions l'iran est
déjà sous sous sanction des normes de
sanctions de la part des américains du
gouvernement 30
et s'ils veulent ajouter des sanctions
ça ne va pas changer grand chose puisque
au bout de trois ans de sanctions l'iran
même si l'économie iranienne ne se porte
pas très bien
l'iran n'a pas changé de position en
iran n'a pas renoncé à ses ambitions
géopolitiques dans la région et affirmer
sa puissance est ce que de nouvelles
sanctions vont changer quelque chose ou
pas je ne pense pas l'important c'est de
que l'iran et les etats-unis puissent
s'accorder sur le programme nucléaire et
que l'iran cesse ses attaques
une fois que l'accord sera signé l'iran
c'est ça cette affaire puisque son
économie va se développer et n'aura
aucun intérêt à apporter de nouvelles
attaques contre d'autres pays ou faire
des actes de sabotage
la dernière question d accusations qui
interviennent alors que le nouveau
président doit être investi cette
semaine est ce que l'arrivée au pouvoir
des vins livre ici peut changer quelque
chose justement danser dans les
relations entre l'iran et l'occident
ça peut changer quelque chose qui sera
ici et disons est le produit du système
il contrôle l'assemblée l'islamic de
l'assemblée nationale iranienne il a
l'appui et le soutien du guide suprême
qui décident plus ou moins de tout et
c'est un ultraconservateur mais pour
négocier les accords sur le nucléaire il
a les mains dit le président oignies qui
est un réformateur
le guide est sûre pour les gardiens de
la rue sans l'empêcher de faire rigoler
dans ce cas-là raïssi qui disposent de
plus des plans to work peut négocier les
termes du nouveau du nouvel accord s'il
estime qu'il doit le signer mais si
jamais il arrive pas à conclure un
accord salle à ça peut être dangereux
parce que comme je vous dédie son ultra
conservateur et il pourra il acceptera
que le pays soit sous pression et que
l'économie s'est trompé mais il va pas
renoncer à 6
et merci beaucoup en tout cas pour
chaque nouveau d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
avocat franco iranien